Bella Hadid steps out in this  jaw-dropping ensemble  talk about making a fashion statement  Bella stepped out in this black sheer  number leaving very little to the  imagination she paired the look with a  black bomber jacket and white thigh high  boots  the model is in Paris for Fashion Week  Bella and Powell kendall Jenner totally  crushed the runway at the Givenchy by  riccardo tisci fall winter 2017 show  [Applause]  meanwhile fellas x the weeknd and Selena  Gomez had another night out together  can't keep my hands to myself a source  tells ET Selena and the weekend showed  up to tenets of the trees in los angeles  on thursday night  you  you